Hi, Corey. I'm fine. Can you hear me?
>> I can hear you. I can hear you well.
>> Okay. Thank you for having me. First, um
I want to say thank you for all of your
teaching. I've learned a lot um watching
you. I've actually been set free. I'm a
recovering Seventh Day Adventist.
>> Man, look at dog gone it. Amen. Amen.
[laughter]
>> Yes. Amen. I I feel like the chains fell
off. Like I've been set free. Mhm.
>> I am I'm happy. I'm no longer afraid.
>> Do you love God any less? Do you love
God any less?
>> I love him more. I'm not afraid of
[laughter]
>> I'm not afraid of him. I just
One thing I do want to tell you that
there are a lot of people just like me
watching your channel who are going to
be set free. So I know you're tired of
the Adventist. you know, I could sense
it watching you, but I would just say if
you can um just have some patience with
them so that more people can come out of
it because it's a heretical teaching,
but they don't know. Corey, I have two
sons who are still there and I'm praying
for them.
When you are a sevenday adventist, you
are brainwashed. You are truly
brainwashed. When I first um was taught
that these Ellen G. White her writings
were not true, I believed it. But it
felt like the very foundation up under
me was shaking. And I was so scared. I
was like, well, who's going to be my
friend? What church will I go to? The
only friends that I truly had were the
women in the church, people that I had
known for for years. So, I went back
into it even though someone had told me
no, she's um these things that she's
teaching is not true. They they actually
showed me where the lies were. And he
said that he and his wife, he went to a
pastor and he exposed some of this to
the pastor. He said, "Well, brother,
yeah, I know, but it's not enough to
throw the baby out with bath water."
>> So, I knew, but I I didn't know where to
go. It was during the beginning of
COVID. I had a habit of wa walking and
as I walked I would listen to sermons
and I was listening to one and the
pastor actually said that Leng White's
writing said that
you should give your house to the church
so that the church can help other
brothers and sisters in Christ. And so
it was a woman in the chat and I thought
to myself, I can't wait to get home so I
can look this writing up to see if it's
true. I went home and I looked it up and
it was true. I found it. And so I was in
the comment section and it was a lady
there. She was like, "Well, I own my
home, but if I give it to the church,
where would I live?" And another sister
said, "Don't do that. Don't become a
burden on your family." And it was at
that point I was like, "I've had enough.
This is craziness." Wow. Um, and I and I
typed in there. I was like, well, I
believe uh because he said it was
scriptural that you could do this
because when they brought everything
that Peter I believe it was Peter and
another um um another apostle that the
church had more than they needed that
stopped giving. And I told her, I said,
I believe also that everyone's needs
were taken care of. Mhm.
>> Is this man after you give your home to
him, is he going to pay for your
medications, your food, anything that
you need? Like, don't do that. It was at
that point that I was like, I had
enough. But I didn't have information.
So, one day I was watching um Sir Walter
Jones show and I was trying to learn,
but I couldn't keep up because as as
Adventists, you're taught certain
things. You're steered in your learning.
They they teach you what they want you
to know. So they were talking about
Jesus coming back and setting up his
capital in Jerusalem. I'm like, what are
you guys talking about? Everyone knows
when Jesus comes back, we're all going
he's going to take us all. The wicked
are going to be slain. We're going to
heaven. We're going to have a
thousand-year period there with him. And
then he's going to come back again. And
then that's when, you know, the wicked
are going to get the hellfire. Well, it
wasn't I couldn't keep up with the sir
Walter Jones. I just couldn't keep up
because because I didn't have a
foundation yet of any truth. So, I I had
begun to watch your channel and that's
slowly just very slowly just listening
to what you had to say and everything
you had to say. I would look it up. I
would fact check everything you had to
say. And it was then when I started
realizing that I had been lied to about
so many things. The state of the dead,
atonement,
um let's see, the Sabbath. It's it's
just so many things that have been lied
to. And these things are like
foundational things. It's not like
little things, little cracks. No, these
are things that it that you need to get
right. you have to get right. And so
[clears throat]
as as I watched and learned more and
more, I uh began to slowly understand.
And then one day you had God logic on
your channel. And I was like, "Okay,
well, I like listening to him. I want to
listen to him because Corey's going to
get tired of the Adventist." And so
[laughter]
I need I need to have somewhere else I
can go and listen to. And I listened to
him and I began to learn more because
he's teaching the the Muslims as you
know he's as he calls it cooking them.
He's teaching them also. So I began to
learn a lot. And then he had a guy on
there and his channel was called
Answering Adventism. Now this is what I
truly needed. This was the Adventist
>> and yeah, he came out of it. But he has
a whole channel that teaches everything.
So I'm like I I found it. I can direct
my sons there now.
>> But um it's going to take time because
you don't just come out of the Adventist
church because you are truly
brainwashed.
>> And so if you can I know you want to
abandon them.
>> I'm not I'm not going to what it what it
really was is there are
let me see one two there's like four or
five of them that just they just keep
coming and just keep coming like I don't
want to talk to you about the same
thing. Now, if they want to talk about
something else, now I promise you this,
I'm not through with the Seventh Day
Adventist. Uh, as a matter of fact,
probably in a week, not a week, probably
about two or three weeks, uh, I'm going
to do a whole, um, show devoted towards,
and it might be a two-part, it might be
a two-parter, uh, where we're going to
cover their beliefs. We're going to say
what they say. We're going to go to go
to their to their site what they have
written what they have written down and
then also what some of them say on you
know out of their own mouths what they
say one of them asked I asked him about
the Sabbath matter of fact one guy even
said if you can prove or show me where
any of us said that if you don't keep
the Sabbath that you go to hell and so I
played three of them and like so you you
are saying so you you you [snorts] said
if I don't keep the Sabbath then I will
I will depart from Jesus or I'm I'm
going to be separated. I'm a cursed.
Okay, that's what I've been saying. We
didn't say that. You just said that. And
so, I don't know if some of them are
intentionally being deceptive or they
just, you know, sometimes you just
honestly want to defend your your home
territory
that happens, but in the end, some of
the things that, and you know this, that
they hold to are just
blasphemously egregious. the the
investigative uh judgment
>> judgment
>> and and how they deal with the the
atonement. Some of these things are just
are just wrong. Even it's not to the
same level. Um the whole the whole Jesus
and and and and Michael, but it kind of
is there. There are some small things
and there are some big things that just
said this is just dangerous. And so
anytime you come across a belief, a a
system of belief that is brand new, your
antennas have to go up and say, "Wait a
second. This has only been around for a
short amount of time. Why didn't the
saints prior to uh the Millerites and LG
White and so forth, why didn't other
people catch on to this? Uh but it's
it's that belief that we are the true
church and that's kind of one of the
hallmarks of of a cult. And sometimes
you you get you you can get caught up in
that. You know, I I've seen
denominations
where they're not a cult, but some of
them have cult-like attitudes where they
say, "Well, this is this is where the
spirit of the god, the the true spirit
of God resides in this church, in this
denomination." I've seen that. Not now.
And some of you guys who are Assemblies
of God, I'm not saying Assemblies of
God, but I did hear one Assemblies of
God preacher saying that. I understand
may maybe he's just, you know, talking
about his home team. Uh but it sound it
sounded cultish. Now, most assemblies of
God, people don't say that. This
particular guy did. I can see I see
folks doing that from time to time. They
do it with other doctrinal issues. Uh
that the the true believers are free
grace. The true believers are
Calvinists. The true believers are
Armenian. The No, let's not do that. But
this right here that they're doing, it's
akin to what Jehovah's Witnesses are
doing. It's akin to what Mormons are
doing. And one of the things I did not
realize until our brother trap Chaplain
Trey pointed out all of these all of
these movements a lot of these movements
started at the same time here in America
at the same time. Um and so you have uh
the Millerite movement and LG White
around the same time as Jehovah's
Witness the same time as Mormons and so
forth and this this transcendental med
meditation movement you had a lot of
these things happen at the same time.
It's like wow what was happening then?
And so we'll talk about that as well. I
think it's pretty fascinating and
interesting to know.
>> But uh I'm not stopping on them. I'm
not. I'm not. I promise you I'm not. I'm
going to um and when I when I they're
going to hate me. They're going to be
mad at me. Um they do this thing this uh
this slight of hand. They have I I don't
know the name of this guy who they had
on one of their shows who was saying
that uh the Greek No, no, no, no, no,
no. the the church read this particular
verse this way
and this is how it would have been read
in the Aramaic which meant if it's read
differently or said differently then
there must be some sort of textual
variant one of the translations or one
of the manuscripts says it differently
it doesn't even have to be in the Greek
manuscript it can be in an Aramaic uh
manuscript or a um a Hebrew or a Latin
or any any sort of translation that
comes in a different language, it would
show it differently. Well, when I go to
this particular verse, which is Hebrews
4:9, there is no such translation that's
different. Every single translation,
every manuscript, whether it be in
Greek, Aramaic, uh, where the Sierra
version, whether it is Latin, whatever
it is, they all say the exact same
thing. So, but they said that on their
broadcast because other people, mo, the
majority of folks don't know Greek or
know how to look this stuff up. Um,
matter of fact, most folks that even
read wouldn't wouldn't look it up. But
because we have to learn textual
criticism at this particular seminary,
>> let me look at this for a second. Huh?
And I see what there is no known
variant. So, they lied, but it's a lie
that might be hard for some folks to
detect. Um,
and and I notice they haven't come they
they normally give a re a rebuttal when
I say something like that. They haven't
given a rebuttal because there is none.
These people came on and they lied to
people uh intentionally. this is these
people are uh unwitting or maybe witting
participants in a cult. And so I I can
promise you this, sister, we're not I'm
glad you're out of it. Uh and I'm glad
you said what you said because people
need to hear your voice to know that hey
cuz sometimes it's just good to know
other people have left. You know what I
mean?
>> If I look around and and
>> ain't nobody else going to leave. I
don't want to be the first one or I
don't want to be the only one of the few
one. But if they see you, your voice
will give other people courage to leave.
>> Yes. Well, thank you for that. Um, it it
it it it is it is hard. All of my um
sisters in Christ are in the church and
Adventists will not tell you this, but
we are taught in Adventist church, if
you know about the seventh day Sabbath,
you worship on the Sabbath and then you
find yourself in a Sunday church, you're
not worshiping on Sunday, you're going
to hell. Now, I've heard them on other
platforms deny that, but that's not
true. I was in Adventist church, but it
is true. My own son told me that. And
when I when I um called him on it about
a month later, he was trying to say he
didn't say that. I said, "TJ, you
believe that. I know you said it. I
remember it because that's what you
believe." I said, "Son, but I'm not
going to hell. I believe Jesus is who he
says that he is. I believe he's the son
of God. He died for my sins. I'm safe.
It's just that I've been set free. I
don't have to live by all these rules."
When I became Adventist, I was a
teenager and we were taught that you
can't dance, you can't go into a movie
theater, you can't wear makeup. It was
all these things you cannot do. You have
it was fundamental beliefs. You have to
believe in the um word of LG White's
writings. If you question her writings,
you're not saved. You can't question her
writings. There there's so many things
that are not true, just lies. And so
they're not going to tell you the truth.
>> Is this true? I don't know this to be
the case, but you could tell, you could
validate this for me, but I've heard it
said, I know this happens a lot of times
with with Jehovah's Witnesses as well
and Mormons um and Muslims that if you
leave,
um there is almost a smear campaign and
attack that comes at you for some
people.
>> You're looked down upon.
>> You're you're looked down upon. You're
definitely going to hell. The first time
I sat in a first day church, and that's
what we call it, first day church. I
looked around. I was like, "Boy, if my
sisters could see me, they're Mary's
going to hell." Surely they would say
that Mary's going to hell. That's what
they that's what they believe. They
truly believe it. So, it could be, I
don't know, a smear campaign, but they
they would talk about you. You know, it
would be whispers like, "What's wrong
with her? She's brainwashed.
She's on her way to hell, you know. But
I don't I don't know about the shining
thing, but you know, it's a different
time now. I'm older. When I became an
Adventist, I was a teenager. I'm 58 now,
so things are more laxed than they used
to be. You cannot eat meat.
>> If you eat meat, you're going to hell.
And definitely if you eat pork,
>> you know, so not all of them would say
all meat, but definitely pork. You're
going to hell for pork. That's for sure.
H
>> Corey, I used to walk through.
>> Look at all the teenagers.
>> I'm sitting there think I'm thinking
about bacon, right? I'm thinking about
bacon right now. Dog on it.
>> Oh my good. Corey, you have no idea. I
was a teenager when I became Adventist,
so I know what bacon tastes like. So I
spent so many years walking past bacon
in the grocery store really wanting
some. And [laughter] so now now if I
want some bacon, I don't eat it much,
but I have eaten it. Okay. But and now I
feel free. I don't think I'm gonna go to
hell. Now, is it good for you? No. It's
not good for you. But are you gonna go
to hell because you eat it? Yeah.
>> And you and I was trying to explain this
to my son because
>> and then I had him look up the verses
and I'm like TJ, we were lied to. I was
actually told that when God said,
"Peter, arise, kill, and eat." I was
always caught, "No, that only had to do
with um the the Gentiles. Don't think
that they're unclean." It wasn't until
recently I found out that not only yes
that too but food also. And in the
writings it says don't let anybody judge
you on what you eat or drink. No sister
it's not that. It's not talking about
food. That's spiritual food.
>> Yeah. They they they when I've had these
conversations with they always explain
away everything. So you know what you've
got to explain away everything that
nobody in the church ever believed. You
take it one way. Whereas well let's see.
Whereas, 1800 years prior, no one
thought what you thought. So, it's just
now. And so, we had to wait for you guys
to show up. You guys are And as I told
him, I said, and I I said, "Brother, I
love you, but you are a heretic. You are
in a you are you were involved in a
heresy." And now, do I think that all
Seventh Day Adventists are going to
hell? No, I don't think that. Uh, some
might because I think if because I I
know that every group has people who
don't know what all they believe. You
might just be following along. Like I
know some folks who were in Jehovah's
Witnesses who were Jehovah's Witnesses
who did know all the teachings of
Jehovah's Witnesses, but they did accept
that Jesus died for their sin. Um they
understood that part. They weren't they
weren't um ingratiated as they got into
it because if you're truly saved, I
don't care where you're saved, the
spirit moves in you and will eventually
move you away from where you don't need
to be if you're if you're growing,
right? Which sounds like what which it
sounds like that's what happened to you.
And so
>> people are saved there. There are a lot
of there are a lot of brothers and
sisters that are trapped in other places
that just haven't gotten to uh the point
that you've gotten to. And so, praise
God for you you doing it. Again, the
good news is that folks can look and
see, hey, here's a sister here who is
saying what she's saying and that other
folks I I can promise you other people
will be emboldened because of because of
your words. You you probably don't know
how many folks you're going to help just
by you saying what you said.
>> Well, that's good to know. That's good
to know. And okay, Corey,
>> I am here in the DFW and when you start
that church, I want to help. I want to
spend my life building the body of
Christ.
[music]